So, we've gotten a lot of feedback
now from a couple of different users.
Next, we need to figure out if
the prototype did well or poorly.
Remember, we don't need to
have users love our app
design as a whole at this point.
We are working with a low fidelity
prototype, so our goal is simply to get
a sense of whether the story
of the app makes sense.
Could users go through and
actually make sense of the app?
Could they do the things
we wanted them to?
When considering whether the prototype
got us the information we needed,
we need to look at whether we have
answers to all the critical questions
around our app's story.
Questions about how to fix flaws in
our app, after we have found them,
may also become critical.
The only way to find this out is to look
at the feedback we got from our users.
Here I have the notes I took from
the conversation with Hugh and
Poornima about this, and it looks like
we got pretty solid feedback on that.
Both of them jumped straight to
the floating action button, and
were certain that it
did the right thing.
We can call that part
of our app a success.